[Music]
every time I think we've beaten him he
comes back stronger crowds here we have
to have this those gorillas get over
that bridge over on the city
we are way out numbers here any pointers
go for the legs
it's army to be here any second
here
will
hey everybody is Charlie a lot of you
had questions after the last episode we
got some new footage let's break it down
oh my Grod this is gonna be so crazy so
if you guys are new to the channel I do
flash videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there's even a new giveaway going on for
a copy of injustice that game I'll
explain at the end of the video but
basically what you have here is the
flash family like a limited version of
the flash family there are still a
couple speedsters that we don't have on
the show yet like Jay Garrick isn't here
helping them out but it's them versus
Grodd and his army the cool thing about
this is that there are a couple times in
the comics that this actually feels like
so way back in 99 there was this Martian
Manhunter comic where Grodd tricks the
other apes into a war with Central City
the other more recent time was during
the new 52 a lot of you are familiar
with King Grodd he had limited Speed
Force abilities which isn't exactly
what's going on in the TV show so I'll
explain that in a second because it was
a pretty cool story but you have Jesse
quick and wall-e that are now working as
a team which is awesome very sort of
calling the shots you have Harrison
wells hooking someone up to that device
that they used to communicate with
sabotage it looks like they might be
trying to counter Grodd psionic
abilities that he's controlling other
people with like we saw that shot of
gypsy she definitely looks like she's
being mind-controlled so cisco is
probably gonna try and help her when
they find that big WTF twist oh my god
gypsy why are you helping them what's
going on Cisco looks like he's getting
his ass handed to him here there's like
all these Valentine's Day things hanging
around maybe this is their version of
the Valentine's Day episode like oh my
god gypsy is coming back so maybe she
tricks him that's part of how Grodd gets
his army over but gypsy is a good
character I do think that they'll
continue to use her on the show she's
too cool for them to not keep using so
somehow they're gonna have to rescue her
from graz control and then you have the
military coming in I don't think this is
general Eiling at least it doesn't look
like him but he's a really big Grodd
character so if Clancy Brown was
available they probably got him but it
might be one of those men knew been it
situations we're like they want to get
Deathstroke on era they're totally happy
to do him Manu Bennett is a series
regular on another TV show shannara
chronicles' that shoots in New Zealand
so most of the time he wouldn't be able
to get star
arrow even if he wanted to and it's the
same thing with Linda Park now I know a
lot of you are like hey wait a minute
Wally's going out with Jesse quick that
didn't happen in the comics he needs to
go out with Linda Park so the thing
about that is that the actress that
plays Linda Park is now a series regular
on shannara chronicles' ironically the
same show that Manu Bennett is on so
Deathstroke and Linda Park are on the
same show shooting in New Zealand
halfway across the world so that's why
you haven't seen them again that
recently in the actress that plays patty
spivot too a lot of you've asked about
her she's also a series regular on a
show on TNT so usually bringing people
like that back is just an availability
question like Mark Hamill for instance
plans his guest appearances almost a
year in advance and even like when he
came on as the trickster this past year
it was a very brief appearance because
of his Star Wars shooting schedule so
the other big thing about this the flash
in the comics was only able to defeat
king Grodd at least during the new 52
the Speed Force version of Grodd by
sucking him into the Speed Force and
trapping him that's probably not gonna
happen on this TV show there have been
other earlier fights with Grodd with non
Speed Force Power Grodd where he's able
to defeat him but a lot of times is only
with the help of Sola bar so a big part
of the recent episode was in flash
refusing to kill Sola bar we didn't see
what garage did with him at the end of
the episode he probably just had a bunch
of apes carry him up and throw him in a
Cell but he did reveal that the reason
that he needed the Flash's help in the
first place is because he was not
powerful enough to stop solo part by
himself meaning this so levar can beat
Grodd in a fight
so Sola bar is the key to this next
episode so let me know in the comments
how long do you think it's gonna be in
this next episode before they have the
idea to get Sola Bart's help before he
enters the fight it's totally possible
they could have some of the resolution
the flash family can defeat really big
billons and Grodd is kind of like a
warm-up force avatar like the flash
family will have to work together to
defeats avatar at the end of the season
but it's completely dependent on their
tactics their ability to work as a team
and Barry's ability to work as a leader
and coordinate their attack so who is
the word
about battle planning and coordinating
with other speedsters wally west he
literally just did that in this last
episode he and Jesse come upon some
robbers and he just rushes right in hold
on I got this and he just goes in and
takes them down so what happened the
last time the flash rushed in and tried
to take down Korat he got his ass handed
to him so there might be a couple funny
moments like that where the flash family
just has to double down it come up with
a different plan the same thing happened
in the last episode when he was fighting
so levar you need to do something that
you've never done before use a reverse
flash trick so a big part of fighting
Grodd effectively in this next episode
is in learning a couple new tricks or at
least using tricks that you know about
that you've never tried before a lot of
you have also asked why doesn't garage
just mind-control one of the speedsters
there been a couple weird explanations
for this in the comics during the Wally
West era when the ginger Wally West was
the main version of the flash in the red
costume they said that his brain
functioned too quickly for God to
control that was a bit of a crazy
explainer but we did see the Grodd was
able to telepathically communicate with
the flash so he can still give him
really crazy visions but they're not
quite as susceptible to mind control as
say normal people are or even people
like Cisco or gypsy gypsies way more
powerful than Cisco and what about the
red lightning a lot of you have asked me
about the red lightning in the last
episode like is this an error what's
going on with Barry part of it I think
is mostly just to differentiate that
visually it's not so much a speed think
technically Barry is faster than both of
these versions of the flash right now
faster than Jesse quick and faster than
Wally West now he's trying to make Wally
West faster than he is but unless
there's some giant derp Barry is still
the fastest version of the flash but
technically if Barry was faster if
you're going by the visible spectrum
then Barry's lightning would be a little
bit closer to blue like it would be a
brighter color not a duller color like
red so maybe they'll have a moment like
that where they explain it on the TV
show but really I think it's just a
visual thing like
not going exactly by the comics there's
always a few differences between the TV
show the comics the movies even do the
same thing too but the other big
question that I got after the last
episode is why didn't Grodd just
mind-control Cisco the first time
instead of engineering this big
situation with gypsy and that's mostly
because of the way he needed to convince
the other gorillas what was going on it
was all a bunch of trickery on his part
look the humans are invading they're
trying to hurt us we need to fight them
or else they're gonna kill us
so Grodd can mind-control a bunch of
other gorillas but he can't control
everybody he can't mind control that
whole army so he needs them to believe
that the humans are a threat so that's
the whole reason why he couldn't just
mind-control Cisco from the beginning
and just take them all over immediately
that gets back to the idea of sola bard
the fact that there are good gorillas so
as long as you can get rid of Grodd and
show the other gorillas that he's evil
they will stop attacking Central City
because a look at that army there is no
way they're gonna beat all them at the
same time that's probably the big twist
of the episode they can't defeat Grodd
they have to find a way to discredit him
so that the other gorillas stop on their
own but it's gonna be a crazy episode
you can definitely see they funneled a
lot of their budget from this two-parter
into this part like this crazy attack
with the giant guerrilla army so the
schedule because so much comic-book
stuff happened this week that I need to
get through the schedule is gonna be a
little bit different so a bunch of you
requested that I do agents of shield so
what I'm gonna do next for my video
later tonight is it'll be infinity war
Inhumans and agents of shield that'll
post in a couple hours and then Thursday
I'll do my arrow video with legends of
tomorrow in the same video just because
there's so much stuff going on because I
got some Thor Ragnarok there's new
guardians of the galaxy there's even
more Star Wars an infinity war that I'll
try to get out on Friday so it's just
gonna be crazy the next couple days and
I don't want to try to do more than two
videos a day so giveaway there's a new
round of the injustice to give away I'm
giving away a copy of the game all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Alan Garcia please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details so in
New Avengers Inhumans shield posting in
a couple hours while you wait for that
you can click here for my flash episode
and you can click here to learn all
about the Sabbat our prophecy thank you
so much for watching well you wait for
that you can click here for my flash
episode and you can click here to learn
all about Wonder Woman Ares thank you so
much for watching let's high-five I'll
see you guys in the next video